Let's take a look at what
the Analytics Dashboard reveals
about the path that users
take to buy products.
You go to the Shopping Behavior page and
you should now see some
sessions with transactions.
Now let's look at the checkout behavior.
So this screen shows the sessions where
users got as far as the checkout step.
So we had seven sessions where
they started checkout and
two sessions that ended
in a transaction.
We'll look more into how you
can track users' progress
through the checkout
process in a minute.
Now let's look at
the Product Performance Screen.
Earlier, you saw that this screen shows
all the products that have been included
in analytics hits.
But up until now, there was zero
revenue associated with any of them.
But you expect that to change now
that some actual sales have occurred.
Oh and it has $15.00 for dinner.
So here we see the revenue for
the products that were included
in the purchase actions.
You can drill down into
the products to get more details.
So we see that these three
dinners here got bought.
There's money associated with them.
And these other dinners
did not get bought.
So again you can set
a secondary dimension,
if you want to see the labels for the
products: Ecommerce > Product Variant.
And now I can see which dinners
were the ones that got bought.
So the product SKU, also pronounced
skew, is the ID for the product.
SKU is a stock keeping unit.
It's something that retailers
use to uniquely identify
each product they sell.
So here it's called product SKU,
but here in the code,
we talk about the product ID,
but actually it's just the ID.
The method that sets it is setId.
You can drill down into the Products.
I didn't set any coupon code or
affiliations.
But you can see that this is where
they would show up if you'd set them.
You can also see other kinds of
information, such as the quantity that
got added to the cart, and the quantity
that got removed from the cart.
And, of course, for
a remove cart hit to be registered,
you'd actually have to write the code to
send that hit in the method that
implemented the remove from cart action.